cuando nancy pelosi se reunió con la
presidenta de taiwán sign en su visita
ya había desatado la ira de china para
beijing la isla autogobernada es parte
de su territorio y la visita de pelosi
es una forma de cuestionar su soberanía
la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu fue directa a la
hora de abordar la situación en taiwán
hoy el mundo se enfrenta a una elección
entre la democracia y la autocracia en
taiwán y en todo el mundo la
determinación de eeuu sigue siendo
fernando burgos
desde 1979 eeuu ha mantenido una línea
ambigua sobre taiwán adoptando la
política de una sola china que reconoce
beijing aún así eeuu mantiene vínculos
no oficiales con taiwán y proporciona a
la isla armas de defensa
la presidenta taiwanesa se mostró
desafiante ante la política de una sola
china frente a las amenazas militares
taiwán no retrocederá defenderemos con
firmeza la soberanía de nuestra nación y
seguiremos manteniendo la línea de
defensa de la democracia la última vez
que un presidente de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu visitó taiwán fue
hace 25 años hoy la atención es mucho
mayor las relaciones entre washington y
beijing se han deteriorado en los
últimos años y ahora china condena los
últimos movimientos como una amenaza
para la paz en la región
eeuu no debería soñar con obstruir la
reunificación de china taiwán es una
parte de china la reunificación completa
de china es una tendencia inevitable de
la historia lo dejaremos espacio las
fuerzas independentistas de taiwán de
las injerencias externas
en la visita a beijing a realizar
simulacros aéreos y marítimos mientras
taiwán dice que los ejercicios chinos
violan su soberanía